peter king the peripatetic peter king
been traveling he's been to 21 nfl camps
including most recently the browns colts
rams chargers cowboys texans saints
broncos and the 49ers and the chiefs as
well
and peter joins us on the program let me
start with the browns how would you
describe the atmosphere at browns camp
i'd say
the vast majority of people inside it
including the
uh the heir to the quarterback job this
year jacoby percent
are mostly blissfully unaware
and
uh have been they've done a good job
starting with kevin stefanski who
basically is allowing andrew barry the
general manager in the haslams to handle
all this stuff
he's just handling it's the proverbial
control what you can control dan that's
what stefanski's doing jacoby bersette
is
when i say he's blissfully unaware i had
a conversation with him it's all like he
just you know that's not part of his job
so he doesn't really care he cares but
he doesn't really concern himself with
it on a day-to-day basis jimmy garoppolo
joining the browns
any traction on that
i think it's unlikely i don't think it's
impossible
i don't think the browns believe that a
quarterback coming onto their team
for a significant amount of money
early in the year is going to have any
impact at all because he won't know the
system he'll have to learn on the fly
you know he's not significantly better
than brissette in their eyes anyway
i would have thought
that
uh i still think they may pick up
somebody or trade a seven for somebody
if they have to a lesser quarterback
you know like mullins gets traded the
other day from the raiders to the
vikings that would have been a guy he
knows kevin stevansky's system it's that
kind of deal you know like uh a
conditional seventh for somebody's third
round a third uh string quarterback they
could do that
did the browns make desean watson
available
uh no no i never had a chance to i never
had a chance to talk to him uh so no i
never i never i never even saw him when
i was in cleveland
that was right on cue with the dog pound
there behind you peter yeah yeah who let
the dog
[Laughter]
now let the dog out
pete there's a lot of money it feels
like vegas on the eagles this year why
all the love for philadelphia
i think they're a very interesting team
dan because i think jalen hurts
i'm not saying he's a top eight or ten
quarterback but i think jalen hurts
is gonna play well particularly
with a bolstered receiving core
uh i think they have a chance to be
really good and i think right now
they're better than dallas well dallas
losing you know a great offensive
lineman tyrone smith how big a loss is
this
hard to rely on him anyway he's been
hurt almost every year the last five or
six years
but now the the kid who they drafted
from tulsa in the first round almost
certainly is going to have to get ready
to play left tackle and they wanted to
introduce him to the nfl
kind of slowly uh by putting him at left
guard this year but he's probably now
going to have to kick out to tackle and
solve that problem for the cowboys he's
peter king it's must read every monday
morning well you can read it tuesday or
wednesday or thursday or friday it's
football it takes a while football
morning in america and uh
nbcsports.com
how did
how what did you feel coming away from
the niners camp what did you feel going
in what did you feel when you left the
niners camp
well
i felt going in that
um i had this great unknown with trey
lance
dan since he graduated from a fairly
small high school
in minnesota
he's thrown 389 passes in football games
in four years he's thrown an average
of whatever that is 95 passes a year
something and so if you're kyle shanahan
you say we've got a really good defense
and what we need to do is play good
enough on offense to win games 21-17
and in my opinion i think
that the best thing that they can do
right now
far and away the best thing that they
can do
is basically play a system on offense
that that basically features a very
limited
not garoppolo but a very limited form of
the offense that garoppolo ran and
have trey lance get up to speed and
that's what i think kyle shanahan's
gonna do
there's a lot riding on trey lance's
success here peter no question i mean no
question but they you know if you're
gonna draft a guy and you're gonna
you're gonna draft him where they
drafted him
uh you've got to have the faith in them
that you can figure it out and kyle
shanahan is one of the smartest guys in
football
he has to have the faith in his own play
calling ability that he can feature him
i think you're going to see a lot more
too tight end stuff with the niners uh
you're you're going to see them taking
fewer chances on offense
they just want to basically
get this guy up to speed without
exposing him too much early on what did
you take from the uh
dana white story about the raiders
interest in tom brady and rob gronkowski
i mean who hasn't talked to tom
or who had you know
i don't know to me i guess the way i
think of it is dan that he
uh
i'm sure it's true it's it's got to be
true but
i think the way i look at it is
anybody right then in that year when
brady was available who wasn't sincerely
looking into him
is just not very smart i mean why
wouldn't you look into a guy whose game
hasn't declined look at him last year
he's 44 years old he leads the nfl in
passing yards and in touchdown passes i
mean who wouldn't want that he's already
won a super bowl
and and been the best quarterback
statistically in football in the two
years since he left new england anybody
who wouldn't look into that i think is
being irresponsible three years ago
yesterday andrew luck announced his
retirement
where were you
uh
i don't know i was somewhere and i i
think i was writing my column somewhere
and i read it on twitter first from adam
schefter
and i was utterly shocked and then
obviously that night he has the press
conference dan i
this i believe is irreversible he's not
going to entertain the thought of coming
back he's living a good new life
as a father and a husband
i have been told he has not been tempted
one time
to come and play again and you know the
last two or three years
he never ever felt right so
i think he got what he wanted out of
football dan there's very few people in
the 38 years i've covered the nfl who
have as many outside interests as andrew
luck does
and so i don't think he's i don't even
think he's particularly struggling with
it
well i remember when barry sanders
walked away
yeah and but barry was always a mystery
you know that he didn't share much and
he just said
look i'm i'm tired of losing and but
he's going to the hall of fame andrew
luck is not it's still and he doesn't
even talk about this he doesn't do
interviews right yeah
i mean i i just think he wants to be a
person
he got tired of being a headline and i
think he wants to be a person
to live his life privately
uh there's nothing wrong with that um
and he is doing that i think the one
part of his legacy
that i think is really important is that
hey look football's fun it's great you
can make a jillion dollars it's not the
only thing in the world
and i applaud him quite honestly for
walking away and not flirting with
coming back all the time i mean
good for him let him do something else
in his life who says that the only thing
you could ever do
and make a great impact on the world is
playing football
the team or teams that could overachieve
this year every year we feel like
there's four or five that jump up and
four or five that drop out you got a
couple that uh
is somebody gonna make a seismic leaf
like like the bengals did
i don't i don't really see a seismic
leap team but i do think the detroit
lions are gonna hover around 500.
i think they're going to be a really
interesting team they're going to win a
couple games this year where people say
oh my god how'd they win at lambeau
field i they're going to win a couple of
games that tell you that dan campbell is
absolutely unequivocally on the right
path along with gm brad holmes
in the afc i don't think this certainly
would be seismic but i'm going to pick
the chargers to win the west
i think that they have they've got a lot
of answers this offseason they're going
to be much better the run game
absolutely gashed them last year
sebastian joseph day
comes over from the rams excellent run
player
khalil mack we'll find out if he can
stay healthy after missing 10 games with
a foot injury he's 31 years old no
insurance for that obviously but that's
a huge piece for them jc jackson at
corner assuming that his injury isn't a
big deal
and then you know zion johnson to help
rebuild that offensive line to me
i think tom telesco the gm of the
chargers had a great offseason safe
travels pete as always thanks for
joining us
okay dan thank you very much that's
peter king the
star of uh football morning
in america that's every monday that that
comes out